un mois après sa création la mission
d'information sur l'immigration à
mayotte commence dans l'île française
des comores françois baroin le ministre
de l'outre-mer l'avait annoncé après la
crise qu'avait provoqué localement sa
déclaration sur l'éventuelle remise en
cause du droit du sol dans les dom tom
cette députée composent la mission
d'information de l'assemblée nationale 3
ump dont montsûrs kamardine un udf de
socialistes ont de rené dosière le
président et un député pour le groupe
communiste et républicain
pendant quatre jours les députés vont
rencontrer les élus les partis
politiques et les associations pour
recueillir les divers points de vue dès
leur arrivée une douzaine de femmes du
mouvement départementaliste mahorais
avait un message à faire passer
louboutin les grands comoriens qui
pensent que mayotte leur appartient nous
n'en voulons pas nous avons fait le
choix de rester français ils ont choisi
l'indépendance qu'il ne vienne pas nous
embêter
à l'issue de leur mission les députés
s'exprimeront notamment sur
l'opportunité de modifier ou non le
droit du sol à mayotte pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine